and we slowed down an abandoned
checkpoint and I don't know where the
first missile came out of nowhere
hands about 30 feet in front of us
immediately Pierre shouts reverse the
car reverse the car there were two
ukrainians driving as well and five of
us in the car
got stuck we couldn't go back and Pierre
shouted get out of the car everyone get
out of the car in the next second the
second bomb hits right in front of the
left of the car
and that one I went black
and I I was in a dark place
I couldn't feel or see and I'd taken
some shrapnel in the eye and I the
matchbox I shrapnel in my in my neck and
I was I was out I was out dead
and then I saw my my daughter out of
nowhere into this Blackness right in
front of me came my daughter honor
said to me Daddy
gotta get out of the car
real as if she was in front of me
I don't know where she came to me and I
came to and I opened up my eyes and my
instinct took me towards the car door
and I scrambled I pulled myself out and
I got out of the car and the third bomb
hit the car itself right after that hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else